this is the most incredible
role anybody's ever been on in show
business in my opinion uh as a director
i'm talking about the first seven movies
out of the box are all [ __ ] classics
you got uh spinal tap short thing and
then stand by me right and now i would
imagine in your life any studio will do
business with you after that comes out
well here's what's interesting first of
all stand by me
i was nervous about because it was
reflective of my personality i thought
if they if people don't like this
this is what i like to do yeah which is
to marry humor and drama and all that
stuff
then they're not gonna and then it was a
success you know so now i'm thinking
what would i you know i i thought oh
princess bride is my favorite book of
all time
i love it because it has romance and
satire and adventure and the studio had
said uh we'll do whatever you want i
said no no no i said they said whatever
you want i said i want to make a movie
out of the princess pride they said well
not that yeah because anything but that
the reason they said that is that book
was successful but a lot of directors
had tried to make that uh movie right
right and and and they couldn't get it
off the ground right there was francois
truffaut tried to make it robert redford
yes robert redford norman jewison they
were all they all failed at it well they
couldn't get anybody interested because
it is a very oddball
mixture of things i mean to mix satire
and romance and adventure the next movie
that comes up is when harry met sally
which is the all-time classic it was
pretty bold to choose billy crystal as a
leading love interest you know what i
mean because
now to be completely honest and billy
knows this i'm not telling tales he was
my best friend and i was nervous about
doing it with my best what if it again
what if this doesn't work what is this
going to do i had gone to albert brooks
right i had gone to uh
tom hanks right i had talked to uh
michael keaton wow different people
great actors and and and more of a
leading men yeah and that in that time
they yeah you know and then and richard
dreyfuss right richard dreyfuss i talked
to and so it was then i said you know
something billy's the best one and i'm
gonna you know i know he's and i and
billy nailed it hey boy did he not only
did he nail it but he contributed like
crazy the biggest laugh in the movie
i'll have what she's having that was
billy's line i'll have what she's having
he came up with it while we were in
rehearsal right and then like you know
you think he would have played it safe
and said okay i'll do another comedy
romantic comedy this and that then
misery you know you take a stephen king
story and uh misery what a [ __ ] great
movie that was yeah with misery it seems
like james khan was born for that role
he did it great but there were like 20
other guys oh yeah no no i had gone
through robert redford and warren beatty
and william hurt i mean it was you know
kevin kline everybody and then everyone
but james yeah and the james was you
know at that time you know people were
worried about him because of his drug
issue but but he was clean and he said
okay i can do that i said okay and
misery was interesting because i love
thrillers i don't make them right but i
love them i love a good thriller if you
make a really smart thriller i'm you
know the first first one there
but i this one i i understood because
you talked about it before
the pressure of
being successful doing something and
then trying to move away from it which
is what that whole movie is about a guy
who becomes successful writing a certain
type of book and wants to write
something else and that was a stephen
king thing and that's sort of your life
but that's sort of your life because you
keep changing genres and doing all this
different stuff do you think those other
actors for one reason another didn't
work out because that is just a really
difficult role to play because if you
think about it that movie is more like a
play it's two characters and it's also
the the the kathy bates bar i mean the
annie wilks that's the flashy part
that's the really great what does it
mean like kathy bates is such an intense
actress that she used to take the
character home yeah she did it at the
beginning and then i said to her kathy
you don't want to be doing this you're a
good enough actress you have a great
craft
don't do this you're going to make
yourself crazy
oh my god yeah so as a director you have
to start yeah and then i mean the list
goes on this role is a few good men yeah
gee
is that the result of having so much
success because look at the cast maybe
you got tom
yeah all the biggest people at that time
yeah it was a great cast and what was
interesting is that jack nicholson
in the first reading he read it the way
he performed it eventually on screen
and what it did is it sent a signal to
all the young actors there
you better step up
this is you know it was like babe ruth
stepping into the cage and smacking him
into the upper
as a director and you got a guy like
jack nicholson can you make suggestions
and is he open to him oh yeah you just
have to keep your mouth shut no
absolutely i mean every actor is
different some actors like uh hands-on
you know even line readings i mean i
will give if they want them
and some actors like to be left alone
and you just have to gauge that you
can't you will you will sometimes if an
actor asks you for it they'll say to you
how would you do in this line and you'll
do it absolutely absolutely and and
what's good is the really secure actors
will do that